When I first heard about panic attacks, I thought they went something like this:
That you're just like sitting around, hanging out
when all of a sudden:
*gasps*
*loud heartbeats*
*breathing heavily*
Aaaaahhh!
But that is definitely not what happened.
When I had my first panic attack a few years ago,
it was insane.  I like couldn't move, it was so hard to breathe,
my heart was racing, and I just had this like insane inexplicable feeling of fear.
And it was weird, you know, because your head says:
Dude!  Everything is fine.  You're having a great time.
There's no logical reason for this.
But your body responds:
Ahhh!
Panic attacks just suck.  They do.
And I don't know if this happens for you, but for me
it's so much more frustrating because you don't know why it's happening.
Like, I was having a great time when all of a sudden
it just invaded my life.
Ahhh!
And I feel very lucky becasue my therapist gave me
a lot of advice on how to try to deal with it without medication.
Like, cutting down on all that caffeine I was drinking,
and practicing relaxation techniques,
and eating better, and exercising regularly
and all this stuff we know we're suppose to do but we don't.
Until you just absolutely need to, to live.
So, if you are suffering from any kind of panic attack or anxiety
please seek whatever help you need because that shit sucks.
On a lighter note, I am really happy to say that today's episode is sponsored by a book!
Yes a book!  They still exist!
And it's alive!  It's "Alive!"
Well "Alive" is written by New York Times Bestseller
Scott Sigler.  And it's book 1 of the Generations Trilogy that's coming out on July 14th.
So "Alive" is about a teenage girl who wakes up in a coffin
with no memory of who she is or how she got there.
She has to fight her way out only to discover that there is
11 more coffins just like hers.
But the survivors don't have any answers so the reader follows her
as she goes to seek them out.
You can watch the full trailer of "Alive" here and you can purchase the book when it comes out
on July 14th.
There's also going to be a free full-length audiobook that's released on ScottSigler.com/iTunes.
So if you want to subscribe you can get a free chapter every week.
I'm Anna Akana.  You stay awesome.